[Musik]
wer sich mein name da rich dienst
gemacht meister
ich bin hier in der maria theresien
kaserne habe den allgemeinen fachten die
kanal während ausbildung 1 im langen
leben abgeschlossen dann 80 hat dann
wird der ausbildung zu hoch erachtet
personalmanagement positive ab verliert
und in weiterer folge der das unter
offizieren der mine besuchen
ebenfalls positiv abgeschlossen und
jetzt bin ich hier bei der
militärpolizei und endlich bei dem der
beruf näher
um zu besuchen musste ich ein
auswahlverfahren absolvieren
diese fünf tage gedauert da wird man
heute getestet oder psychisch und
physisch geeignet ist dafür und ich muss
sagen jetzt sehr hart dafür trainiert
hierher zu kommen jetzt bin ich endlich
lahr und hoffe dass sie mich auf diesem
wege verfolgen werde
ich werde euch ein paar eindrücke zeigen
was man hier alles so erlernt militär
positionieren
jetzt gehen wir die sache aus fassung
die ich für die nächsten wochen den kurs
benötigen werde
so jetzt endlich eine chance bekommen
das letzte stück war das was hinter mir
liegt also wenn er für die nächsten acht
wochen benötigen
so leute barrett und mp page ebenfalls
gewechselt jetzt heißt es noch zimmer
beziehen
und ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr mich
auch in den nächsten wochen unterstützt
und wie gesagt bleib dran